haben wir gemacht heute haben wir spaß
gemacht und zwar gibt es heute bei uns
spargel im crap eingeholt und mit einer
leckeren wäsche soße und wenn ihr wissen
wollt wie man diese leckere gericht so
bereitet dann bleibt jetzt dran
kinder sind ehrlich weg zu bereiten und
dafür braucht ihr folgende zu 1125 gramm
gehen ganz normales weizenmehl 100
milliliter milch 100 milliliter
mineralwasser sprudeln dass ein ei und
etwas also ganz ohne kleine prise und
aus diesen zutaten werde ich jetzt mit
einem handspiel geräten teig herstellen
können dann natürlich auch ohne
handgerät oder einfach in der
küchenmaschine zuerst gebe ich jetzt
dass medien eine schüssel geben und salz
hinzu und geht etwa die hälfte der milch
dazu dass ganze frühere ich jetzt
erstmal damit sich dort keine klümpchen
durch das mehl bilden
dann gebe ich noch die restliche
flüssigkeit dazu also milch und wasser
und firmiert das ganze noch mal zu einem
platten teil
den teig fertig ist eine halbe stunde
lang stehen lassen wir ihnen einfach ein
bisschen abdecken mit einem teller oder
mit einer folie und werde mich jetzt zum
spargel begeben und wird ihn zubereitet
habe ich hier den sparten habe ich
bereits gewaschen und werden jetzt
gleich scheele und im übrigen nicht dass
ein spargel aus unserem eigenen
schrebergarten wir haben nämlich auch
spargel möglichen gehen da mit meiner
mama und mein papa einmal spargel
stechen ist dann wäre das natürlich auch
nicht fehlen und den sparkurs als eben
noch schälen und beschädigte ihn einfach
von oben nach unten und die schale die
häufig auch sie die bitte nicht
wegschmeißen weil wenn wir jetzt gleich
noch soße dazu machen oder wie zum
beispiel eine spargelsuppe machen sind
dann könnte die schale einfach mit garen
die hat nämlich so viel geschmack dabei
ist echt viel zu schade
das heißt zu schmeißen und müssen hier
in deiner bruchsaler gegend und bei uns
sind überall wirklich spargel gilt bei
uns bekommt man in jedem dorf in jedem
ort spargel die man eben dann frisch vom
acker geerntet hat und bei uns geht's
wirklich überall von spargel frische
erdbeeren und das ist total lecker also
bei uns ist wenn sparkasse song ersparen
in allen variationen
fast so schön wie bei uns im
schwabenland was habt ihr spätzle und da
muss man natürlich nicht fehlen
da ist nämlich der spargel richtig schön
feiern schon weich und vielleicht könnt
ihr mir mal sagen wie ihr euren spargel
am liebsten erst also rückte auch legal
oder gebraten mit die weißen spargel
oder grünen spargeln ich liebe zum
beispiel spargel zu können
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr mit ein
paar rezepte wünsche aufschreiben und
dann kann ich euch ein paar andere
rezepte mit sprache vorstellen
ich hatte meinen spannung geschickt und
wer jetzt den spargel im rat schlafe im
ofen zuzubereiten
ihr könnt ihr natürlich auch in wasser
garen aber ich finde immer ein bisschen
schade wenn man gemüse in wasser gab
weil er dann der ganze geschmack ins
wasser übergeht und wenn ihn das ganze
wasser benutzt dann ist eigentlich der
geschmack umsonst weg und wird meistens
von ihr weggeschüttet oder man nimmt ein
bisschen was für die soße aber
eigentlich wird das ganze wasser nicht
so wirklich benutzt
ich bin es immer super wenn es dampft
amt und entweder kann man jetzt in den
topf machen mit einem kleinen topf mit
zu löchern drin
oder man kann es in dem dampfgarer
machen das haben wir hier in diesem
küchenstudio auch da aber da ja fast
keiner zu hause einen dampfgarer hat
wenn ich jetzt heute so mache mit einem
fahrradschlauch diesem ratschlag gibt es
im supermarkt das ist so eine
und in der kann man dann gemüse fleisch
alles mögliche garten im ofen und es gab
dann in so ein bisschen wasser und wird
dann eben durch den dampf gegart so
findig behälter sparte seine richtigen
geschmack und ich zeige mich jetzt
einfach wie einfach das geht
ich habe hier meine chance kläglich
jetzt kurz zur seite und verwendet sie
später weiter hier habe ich meine
spargel das waren ursprünglich 500 gramm
einen halben teelöffel salz hier habe
ich eine prise zucker und etwas butter
das sind 20 gramm eine halbe zitrone und
etwa 50 milliliter wasser zuerst
schneide ich mir jetzt meine folie zu
recht und zwar muss sie immer etwas
länger sein als das gemüse was ihr rein
gibt
im innern ist jetzt eine kleine folie
und die benutzt ihr dann um die enden
zusammen zu binden
die werde ich jetzt noch halbieren und
mit dem einen ende bin ich jetzt das
eine ende zu drehen eine folie um und
öffnete jetzt ein wenig damit ich da
jetzt durch die öffnung des gemüse
einfühlen kann
dann lege ich den spargel hinein
und gebt dann das wasser hinzu salz und
zucker
wobei es auch vorher gerne in dem wasser
auflösen könnte dann kommt auch direkter
zitronensaft mit dazu einfach für den
besseren geschmack und für die milde
säure und anschließend gebe ich noch die
butter in kleine stückchen mit rein und
vermischtes ganze woche kurz
jetzt wird das andere ende noch zu
gebunden und da achtet ihr bitte darauf
dass ihr ganz viel luft mit einarbeitet
und anschließend müssen noch zwei bis
drei öffnungen oben eingeschnitten
werden
das geht natürlich ganz gut mit einer
schere aber eben auch wie ihr sie mit
einem messer
so kommt der spargel bei etwa 180 grad
ober und unterhitze im vorgeheizten
backofen für etwa zwölf bis 15 minuten
rein und so lange wird er ja auch im
wasser brauchen
die spargel schale gebe ich jetzt mit
etwa 200 milliliter wasser in einen
kleinen topf und lasst es da einfach
köcheln bis der ganze geschmack eben im
wasser ist jetzt werde ich die krebs zu
behalten und gibt dafür etwas butter in
die pfanne und laste schön den schmelzen
gibt dann eine suppe telefon mit dem
teig in die pfanne und bacchus so meine
krebs nach und nach aus ich achte immer
darauf dass meine treppchen will bleiben
aber ihr könnt sie natürlich auch
dunkler braten lassen
so verbraucht jetzt den ganzen
restlichen teig bei mir sind etwa 8
platz entstanden das reich dann von vier
personen
die spargel schale gieße ich dann ab und
fangen das wasser auf die sparten schale
kann man dann wegschmeißen
meine ersparnisse sind jetzt vorbereitet
die kräften aus gebacken und jetzt werde
ich auf die soße zubereiten und ich war
jetzt heute einfach eine ganz einfache
welcher mit soße mit bisschen von diesem
sport ist dafür braucht ihr 40 kaputter
40 gramm mehl etwas milch und diesem
sparkurs und den werde ich jetzt
auffüllen also ich hab jetzt hier
ungefähr 250 milliliter und wer jetzt
mit milch auffüllen auf etwa 500
milliliter
es könnte auch mit gemüse früher machen
oder einfach pur mit milch und hier habe
ich noch etwas sein und wetter noch ein
paar kräuter benutzen
dann gebe ich die butter in einem topf
und ihr seht ich hab da einfach sein
spargeltopf genommen denn muss man dann
auch nicht woher auswaschen gebe da mal
medien zu und mittelmeer schwitzen
das ganze wird ein bisschen angebraten
und dann mit dem gemisch abgelöscht als
mit dem milch gemüsebrühe gemisch ich
gebe dann auch direkt meine kräuter dazu
salz pfeffer
wer möchte noch etwas muskatnuss bei uns
gibt es auch immer ein bisschen chili
mit rein und ihr könnt dann auch kräuter
der wahl verwenden
die soße wird jetzt aufgekocht und soll
es dann etwa bei mittlerer hitze 5
minuten köcheln
ich hätte meine kräfte einen spargel und
meine härteste tam licht und zeigt euch
das ist einfach mal hier den teller mit
dem grab nehmen wir meine spargelhaus
der mich jetzt auch ein bisschen
abkühlen
nehm jetzt einfach so zwei schwager
pfannkuchen also programm entwickelt es
einfach schön ein und nehmen dann meinen
teller und gibt es drauf und da könnt
ihr jetzt einfach noch die sowas mit
dozenten und wenn euch die soße zu dick
ist könne da gerne etwas von der frühe
mit dazu geben aber ich mag es
eigentlich ganz gern so dick damit man
eben auch ein bisschen was von der und
dann könnte das ganze anfang ein
bisschen garniert mit frischen kräutern
das rezept gibt es natürlich zum
nachlesen auf der list orten welt.de
wenn ihr gerne noch weitere spart ihr
rezepte haben wollt dann lasst es mich
gerne in den kommentaren wissen und ich
wünsche euch auf jeden fall ganz viel
spaß machen einen kunden appetit und
bisher uns beim nächsten mal wieder
wiesbaden